believe that a plane has crashed into
the world trade center in new york
less than two hours later and the
manhattan skyline had changed forever
first the south tower and then the north
tower collapse trapping thousands of
people inside
the release of toxic material meant 10
000 people in lower manhattan that day
were impacted many of them contracted
cancer some have since died
but it wasn't just here in new york that
the terrorists had targeted
we believe there has been a third
hijacked of a jumbo jet
we also believe though again not
confirmed but there are reports of an
explosion at the pentagon
[Music]
another plane was headed for washington
but passengers were able to wrestle back
control of the aircraft with united 93
crashing in shanksville pennsylvania
all on board were lost
back in new york the death toll was
continuing to rise despite the best
efforts of the emergency services more
than 400 died that day including 343
firefighters who ran towards danger when
so many thousands of others were running
away
i can hear you the rest of the world
hears you
and the people
[Applause]
and the people who knock these buildings
down
will hear all of us soon
a month later president bush stood
shoulder to shoulder with new york
firefighters as he authorized operation
enduring freedom saying the u.s would
rid the world of the evil doers
20 years on
and america continues to rebuild never
forgetting those that perished on 9 11.
a single rose is added to the names when
those who fell would have had their
birthdays this for carlos manuel morales
this the footprint of the north tower so
many people died that day i was speaking
to a national security adviser just the
other day he told me though
that the security threat to the us is as
high now as it was
on 9 11.
the challenge for president biden as he
visits ground zero is to reassure the
american people that he can protect the
nation